let's bring in Gregg Anthea NBATV Gregg
kind enough to join us I know you're on
a deadline here Greg thanks for joining
us let me start with the news the cabs
have a new head coach and John Beilein
what do you make of this new lines
taking us an NBA job prior to last
season and you know at this point if you
look at Cleveland we've seen this story
play out before with the college coaches
they're not going to be very good that
year so he's a terrific coach you know
he's going to make a ton of money it's
going to give him an opportunity to
probably you know scratch an itch we you
know it's given the opportunity to coach
at the highest level but it's a
tremendous blow to Michigan you know he
had done such a terrific job there and I
got to say I feel a little bit better
now that I didn't get my son didn't
commit to Michigan to go way back back
well cuz I would not be a happy camper
right now would you rather coach the
Cavs or Michigan well and I think it
depends on how much they're gonna pay
and in his case you know at this stage
of his career he probably just wants the
opportunity in the challenge you know
but if it were just there I'm purely to
coaching I would say Michigan you're
gonna have a chance at more success
they're not going a lot of games at
Cleveland next year you know you don't
have as much impact as a coach at the
professional level as you do believe me
because you don't have control over the
roster you know he can't go out and find
five star guys at Cleveland you know he
doesn't have that option he's got to
coach that roster and and that roster is
not going to be very good he's going to
be in a teaching mode which might help
with Cleveland because they do got some
young guys that they want to develop
what did you make of the Lakers higher
Frank Vogel I like Frank Vogel a lot but
the reality is he was not their first
choice it's become a bit of a disaster
in LA with all that's transpired over
the last you know three months you got
to go away back to the trade deadline
they really nothing's going well for LA
which is kind of shocking after you go
back to last summer and they sign
LaBonge and you think everything's going
to head in the right direction and it's
in the absolute opposite so what we'll
have to wait and see but they've already
lost the press conference right because
of how this thing played out with with
fire tyloo and the fact that they only
gave a 3-year deal you know you move
walden a five-year deal to come in when
that team really wasn't destined to do
much you go out and find LeBron and your
answer is we're going to just basically
sign guys so the length of his contract
and just let it play out
we're talking to Greg Anthony NBA TV
called Game seven yesterday between the
Sixers and Raptors have you seen
somebody performed the way Kauai has
performed certainly in that series but
in the playoff so far this year I think
he's been the best player I mean we get
caught up oftentimes just in the stash
in the scoring but you got to remember
how good he is defensively as well and
last last night I mean they had got
nobody else wanted to shoot like before
look at he took 39 shots but just with
the way the game played out he contends
his guys the moment was really big no
one really wanted to step up I thought
Kyle Lowry was solid but other than that
he was basically a one-man wrecking crew
man and that guy was incredible down the
stretch I had to tip my caps on boy I
tell you what it is it's going to be
really interesting that this thing plays
out but I think that series it's going
to be incredible between the walk in
Toronto but just all the ramifications
about whether or not he stays I mean I
don't know that anybody he was already a
let's guy I don't know that anybody
actually helped themselves anymore in
three agencies they're Inquirer winner
I'll leave you with this Greg will the
Rockets system work with James Harden
the way it's constituted
I think the system is fine it's not the
most it's not the prettiest system so
watched but there guys laid an egg and
in that game engage six
that's a mean I just thought they did
not have great focus and they weren't
very disciplined in their game and the
Warriors made a face I know you're on a
travel schedule there we appreciate your
time we'll catch up with you again Greg
thank you that's Greg Anthony and be on
TV
TNT's exclusive presentation of the 2019
Eastern Conference Finals begins
Wednesday May 15th Ernie Kenny Charles
Shaq their Petula the pregame at 8:00
Eastern that's a game one tip 8:30
coming up on Wednesday for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on VR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app